God didn't bring us this far to drop us
off God has a way of humbling me right
now it's the best way that I can
describe it is like grieving the loss of
parents who are still alive
Todd and Julie reported to their
respective prisons today just two months
after receiving a combined sentence of
19 years for bank fraud and tax evasion
there have been reports of you having
said just fix it fix these documents
that's not true as the clock ticked on
their final hours of Freedom Todd was
spotted out yesterday wearing a shirt
that was kind of giving prison stripe
Vibes and Julie in exclusive photos from
the dailymail.com she stocked up on soda
and supplies for the family and they
have some bumpy roads ahead my kids may
have some Buffy roads ahead my husband
but we're going to get through it the
Chrisleys who flaunted their wealth on
their reality shows in a year we
probably spend 300 000 sometimes more
just on clothing we'll be serving time
far from their Nashville mansions Todd's
Federal facility is 440 miles away in
Pensacola Florida Julie's a 216 mile
drive to Lexington Kentucky the couple
will be 655 miles apart as for prison
life well Todd's minimum security
facility is known for being one of the
cushiest in the country and they'll both
be up early lights on for Todd is at 4
45 a.m for Julie it's 6 a.m Todd's
allowed to get a job in prison like
Baker or teacher's aide he can make as
much as 40 cents an hour Julie can take
part in art programs including painting
and sculptures Todd shared one final
video on Instagram before turning
himself in the 53 year old posted this
clip of gospel singer Karen Peck
performing four days late adding the
hashtag fight the good fight what we
will not do is we will not break